("Stringing Along")
- [Man] What's a trustworthy name? Sarah.
- Margaret.
- Oh yeah.
- I trust Emilys.
- Or like girl names that are
guy names like Samantha, Sam.
- Sams are down to earth, like
they wear the baseball cap
and they're cool like that.
But Samanthas on the other hand...
- Samantha's definitely a princess.
- But you like princesses.
I love them.
- Jess' are, they're like a good friend.
They're always down.
- I think you're great at this.
- Yeah?
Jessicas and Laurens are good friends.
- Yeah, Jessicas and
Laurens are always friends.
- They pair really well.
- Yeah, I feel like Jessicas
are some of the sweetest girls I know.
- Jessicas are mean.
Jessies, immediately
are a different person.
They're the kind of people
that literally offer you candy
when you see them, they're like
"Oh, I have some extra candy
"You want some candy?"
- Always carrying candy.
- [Man] Bianca, no,
Bianca's crazy.
- Bianca's a red flag name.
- Because you know what
her friends call her? "B."
- I think the craziest name is Britney.
Britneys have a big range.
- Sophie is crazy, Sophies are crazy.
- Yeah, Sophies are nuts.
- She's the type of chick
that'll like break a bottle.
It's volatile, but it's exciting.
- Jacqueline, you can't
control a Jacqueline.
Jacqueline is like blonde
and like ready to yell.
- Becky's a freak.
- Yeah she is.
- Rebeccas are in charge of Beckys.
Because Becky's drunk.
- And everyone's like,
"Oh, it's just Becky."
- "Rebecca, call us an Uber!"
- Oo, Christine is a total MILF name.
- Christine is a total MILF name.
- You would meet a MILF named Brenda.
- When Brenda is younger
it's that weird phase,
but when Brenda gets to
be a mom, Brenda gets hot.
That's like peak Brenda time.
- Amy, like if your mom's name is Amy.
- Alice would be a MILF name for sure.
- "Hi Mrs. Johnson."
"Don't call me Mrs.
Johnson, call me Alice."
- Oh, yeah, that would get me.
- You'd be like, "Oh
Alice, you're so crazy."
- (laughs)
- [Man] Megan would probably be in charge.
Meg, also would be in charge.
- Olivias are leaders.
- Olivias are like powerful,
like power house women.
- I feel like Olivias are smart.
- Yeah, I feel like
Olivias are very smart.
- Olivias are perfect.
- I kind of feel like
Jade is kind of powerful.
- Jade.
- Maria could be like a boss, I feel like.
- Maria could totally be a boss.
- Maria Gutierrez is my boss.
- Gwen, I bet Gwens are
in charge sometimes.
- Gwen sounds like someone
who could be in charge,
but also very sexy.
- Authority is sexy.
- Absolutely.
- [Man] Hot girl, oh, like Lexi.
- Lexi.
- I think Emmas are hot.
Yeah, cause they got that
Southern sweet thing.
It's like a short little Emma,
and it's like, "Oh, hey."
- Something like Sasha.
- Dude, I was
about to say Sasha!
- about to say Sasha?
Right?
- No, I'm not even kidding.
- Like a tight black dress,
- A quarter Latina
- Yeah, very elegant, but
she's not snobby, Sasha.
- Alexandra's intimidating.
- Alexandra, there's
like a powerful sexuality
about Alexandra.
- Yeah, Alexandra's in
a ball room right now.
- Taylor is one of those girl-boy names.
Across the board, men and women,
they're good looking people
- Guaranteed, if you want
your kid to look good,
just name it Taylor.
- Or like Nicole, I think Nicole
is like a really hot name.
- Nikki and Nicole are both hot.
The difference is Nikki
will burn your clothes
in the front yard when
you break up with her.
- That's a black Nikki.
- (laughs)
- That's a black Nikki,
definitely, I know that Nikki.
("Stringing Along")